à 4 jours du grand chambardement routier
la ministre des Transports est venue
voir ce qui ronge le tunnel et force
cette immense chantier mais après avoir
salué le travail des quelques 250
ouvriers qui seront sur place 22h sur 24
l'essentiel des messages étaient
destinés aux automobilistes ça va être
très corsé à partir de lundi il faut pas
faire semblant que il y a une solution
miraculeuse à portée de main qui va nous
apparaître je pense que la solution elle
réside dans la somme des gestes et des
actions qu'on va chacun poser
le transport en commun demande aux
employeurs de maximiser le télétravail
ou d'offrir des horaires autres que le 9
à 5 mais aussi d'ajuster les horaires de
livraison quant à l'idée de bannir
l'auto solo à l'heure de pointe on n'est
pas en ce moment un stade où on veut
interdire obligé quoi que ce soit on est
dans la très forte recommandation aux
abords de l'autoroute les citoyens
redoutent une invasion de véhicules dans
leur rue ils réclame plus d'informations
de la part du MTQ et une surveillance de
la qualité de l'horaire il y aurait
peut-être intérêt à ce que une station
des championnats soit localisé en
bordure de la 25 l'intensification de la
circulation dans le secteur tient au
fait qu'une seule voie sera réservée
pour sortir de l'île de Montréal une
décision qui s'imposait selon le
consortium quand on faisait au
simulation pour voir un peu à qui on va
donner le voix on voyait qu'en donnant
deux une voix en direction Montréal on
avait des ralentissements des temps de
parcours en tunnel qui donnent des
raisonnables vous voulez pas être pris
30 minutes dans le tunnel c'est un peu
anxiogène depuis cette semaine la
configuration deux voix vers Montréal
est déjà en vigueur résultat aux abords
du contunnel c'est mieux que lors des
simulations nous dit d'entrepreneur mais
le véritable verdict sera rendu par les
automobilistes la semaine prochaine si
Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal